[inaudible]
often people think that Switzerland's
wealth comes only because of their
status as a fiscal haven.
But think about it.
There are other countries like Panama,
Cypress,
the Republic of Liberia,
these all fiscal haven's too,
don't forget Africa,
not 70 offers low taxes to international
companies,
but it also offers them Pasadena
passage.
Let's still,
these countries remained low income
countries.
While Switzerland's remains one of the
wealthiest countries in the world,
and all of this comes with them having
no natural resources not compromising on
democracy or human rights.
[inaudible]
Switzerland has one of the most
egalitarian political systems in the
world,
and its welfare system is as good as
that of Norway,
Denmark.
Additionally,
their citizens,
and not only have the right to vote
every four years,
but every four months,
this was,
don't just choose their leaders,
that they choose their policies with
referendums happening several times a
year,
Switzerland has one of the world's best
political systems,
and we believe that this is the reason
that they are successful.
In fact,
we think that the Swiss system should be
a model for other countries.
And in this video we're going to tell
you why.
[inaudible]
reason number one,
the centralization from a practical
point of view,
it's Switzerland is what is known as a
confederation.
In fact,
it's the only confederation that exists
on the planet.
It is made up of 26 states which are
cold cantons.
The only thing that these cans,
all those have in common are a
constitution,
foreign policy and the currency.
Aside from that,
if they are totally different from one
another,
let's look at an example.
Let's say you make a salary of 6,000
Swiss franc spend.
You live in the region,
all the Jura.
In that case,
you're going to pay income tax of 14%
but if you made the same amounts of
money and you live in the region of
Zuellig,
your income tax is only going to be 4%
look at a different example.
If you have a shop in Geneva,
then you're going to have to close your
shop at 6:00 PM but if you own a shop in
Zurich,
you're free to keep your shop open for
as many hours as you want.
Because of this system that comes on is
can adjust the laws,
the peculiarities of each individual
territory ans what is even more
important than this is that they can
compete with each other.
This
explains why in general,
the councils have assumption,
no taxation,
but our story doesn't end here.
Switzerland is so decentralized that
they have four official languages,
German,
French,
Italian,
and relaunch.
This means that if you happen to go to
Geneva,
which is a French speaking part,
you're not getting to hear anyone
speaking German,
the billboards,
the road signs,
the local newspapers,
everything is in French.
The same goes for Zurich with Jen and
all the Ghana with Italian
[inaudible].
Number two,
Switzerland has no precedent.
Every country has a head of governments
who is responsible for certain things,
right?
Well,
no,
not switzer matters,
but don't get me wrong,
they're not living in anarchy or
anything.
This is what they do.
Is they vote for a federal parliaments,
which is similar to Congress in the
United States of America.
This parliaments and then chooses seven
people who are going to become something
like ministers or secretaries.
All of these people have the same amount
of
power.
Yeah.
One of them takes a turn becoming
Switzerland's international
representative.
It's technically this person is the
president of Switzerland,
but they haven't no specific powers.
Uber,
the other six people and as I said,
they routine this person.
Yeah.
This is an important difference in the
Swiss mentality because in other
countries the president isn't really
powerful.
Passive bought in Switzerland.
It's just a symbolic thing because all
of the decision making is done by a team
[inaudible]
or three direct democracy.
This is the most important part of Swiss
politics.
They're referendums.
In fact,
most of it,
that law was a chosen by a popular vote.
Some at the federal level,
some of the canned tonia level.
The proposal for a referendum only
requires 50,000 signatures.
While one if it's going to amend the
constitution requires 100 thousands now,
don't get me wrong.
Other countries do allow their
populations to have referendums.
For example,
in Spain,
this is totally possible,
but a referendum proposal requires
500,000 signatures and they can't do any
referendums that will change the culture
tuition because of this
system.
Switzerland's holds several referendums
every single year,
every four months this waste go to the
polling station and they will vote on
any proposals that have been put forward
in the previous four months.
Now,
let's look at an example of one of these
referendums from the year 2015 if they
have to choose whether they wanted to
create a basic income for every Swiss
citizen.
They said no.
By the way,
they also had to decide on some
amendments to the assisted reproduction
acts and they also about to vote on some
doors related to public transport.
Interestingly,
these,
yeah,
Paul's awesome having really big
turnout.
60% of Swiss people for this 2015
referendum when to the polls
[inaudible] some number
for free markets.
Some of you might think that it's very
easy for a populist anticapitalist
leader to emerge in a system like this,
but make no mistake Switzerland is to
the free markets like France is to it's
wine.
Don't forget,
this country is isolated in the
mountains and has practically no farming
land.
This means that it's have to sign a free
trade agreements with pretty much every
country on it.
Well,
it's hold on my deal.
Libertarian friends who are watching
this video,
hold on for just second.
Yes,
it is true that Switzerland is a
commerce loving nation.
No more so than the European Union.
[inaudible].
This is the Swiss actually subsidize
that agriculture as much as the
Europeans or the Americans do and they
also participate in the same trade
embargoes that exist with Iran and
Russia.
The only differences that Switzerland
has embraced free trade since 1874 while
the rest of the world's is only been
doing it for the last few decades and
now there is another very important
difference about Switzerland,
but we must get into,
and it's probably one that you've heard
about recent number five Swiss,
no tragedy.
Switzerland is one of the few neutral
countries in the world.
This means that they won't participate
in any arms conflict.
They even stayed out of world water you
despite the fact that most of the
population was against Hitler.
Thanks to this,
Switzerland has never been reconstructed
while the rest of Europe ripped itself
apart,
killing millions and then spending
billions in reconstruction.
Switzerland didn't and they used all of
those savings to improve that system.
As we all know,
the number one enemy of economic
progress is
Switzerland does have a military.
The thing is this army is entirely
defensive and they will only use it to
propel external attacks.
They will never use it to find it in
anything outside of self defense,
and this is where we see one of the few
drawbacks of the Swiss system.
They're military or should we say them
initia every Swiss citizen must do
military service from the age of 18 to
the age of 30 spending one month every
single year serving in the military and
even after that service period they miss
still keep a gun at home.
Of course it Switzerland's isn't the
only country that does this with Norway
and Israel.
Also having mandatory military sentence.
People argue that this system is good
with pundits saying that it creates more
entrepreneurs and creates less income
disparity.
Don't forget that during that time in
the military,
the rich and the poor on mixing together
several startups and companies have been
created from relationships that were
formed while people were serving in the
military.
But the big question is what about
liberty?
What about the freedom to choose?
What gives the government the right to
force you to work in a place that you
might not want to work?
Of course we don't have the answers to
these questions,
but they are just something for you to
ponder.
Yeah.
Number
six,
ease of doing business.
Finally,
inventing is perhaps the most well known
to thing about Switzerland am's.
That is that taxes.
It's true despite the differences from
one council to another,
Switzerland does typically have very low
taxation.
Further the laws to start a company.
I'll a fairly simple and anyone can see
those laws buying.
Just giving online.
Switzerland is one of the most
transparent freeze in the world.
This is encouraged a lots of
international companies to establish
their fiscal residents in Switzerland,
but it also makes it very easy for
people in Switzerland to set up their
company and yes.
Okay,
okay.
Banks do make up a large part of the
Swiss economy,
but it's probably not as big as you.
Yeah.
Oh,
many,
many other industries in Switzerland.
It doesn't mean logitech mean anything
to you.
Well,
look at your mouse.
Look at your Webcam.
You'll probably see it printed on one of
those things.
And this is a company that was formed in
Switzerland and then there's the
pharmaceuticals to the names,
Novartis or Hoffman Laroche Ring.
Any bells?
Not to mention,
of course,
tourism,
precision machinery.
I'm that famous swaptions.
I'm pretty sure you could mean five
companies that are from Switzerland are
simply buying meanings and expensive
watch brands.
Ooh.
This is being done in a country with a
population that is smaller than New York
City.
As we always say,
visual politic.
It is not a country's natural resources
and it is not luck.
The determine whether they are
successful.
It's their system of government and the
institutions that do this.
And we believe that the Swiss have a lot
to teach the rest of the world in this
regard.
Just our opinion.
Do you agree with us?
Do you disagree with us at?
Do you think that your country could
benefit from a system more in length,
the Swiss?
Well,
let me know what you think in the
comments below.
And don't forget that we upload brand
new videos every Monday,
every Thursday.
So you do click that subscribe button,
and if you would like to dig deeper on
this topic and find out more about the
Swiss system,
I will put some links in the description
below.
And if you liked this video,
don't forget to give it a thumbs up
below and I'll see you in it.
[inaudible].